bon nouvelle saison de vidéos est
derrière vous avez plus qu mls haderer
dit et surtout laisserait d'horreur
quand je tombais sur des threads twitter
je suis je me disais ils font tous
martelé pour je le fasse et sarah départ
je recevais du midd message aujourd'hui
on va pas aller sur twitter pour trouver
un thread qui est en fait une fiction à
tout laisserait de twitter qu'on a fait
c'est et des fictions à chaque fois
qu'ils étaient hyper cool mais ces
défections on va retourner sur le sobre
et dit let's not mais où je le rappelle
les gens il raconte des trucs pas très
cool qu'ils ont vécu pas forcément
paranormal mais des trucs très flippant
très creepy on en avait déjà fait
plusieurs may avait pas des nouvelles
histoires qui est des genres folk été
transcendante qui nous mettait dans tous
nos états qui nous donnait envie de ne
plus dormir pendant un mois et pas
aujourd'hui je les hais ces histoires
elle date de quelques années toutes
celles là mais je suis allé piocher très
très loin pour les trouver mais elles
sont horribles laissez moi vous raconter
l'histoire de john je la déteste john
vit en floride est ce que je vais vous
raconter c'est passé trois semaines
après l'ouragan irène qu'est-ce qu'on en
a à [ __ ] me direz vous allez voir ça a
son importance
quelques mois auparavant il a divorcé
avec sa famille l'a donc emménagé dans
un nouveau quartier qui est un quartier
fermé dans lequel chaque maison
appartient au même propriétaire ou à la
même société de location c'est un petit
quartier et environ 15 maisons et elles
sont toutes autour d'un lac artificiel
comme c'est un petit quartier tout le
monde se connaît il ya régulièrement des
faits des petits barbecue qui sont
organisées tout le monde y va mais pas
john qui est très déprimé de son divorce
et qui préfère pas trop aller à des
événements sociaux comme ça mais il
s'est quand même fait un pote c'est son
voisin d'à côté qui s'appelle steve et
qui est un ancien marine ça mais en
haleine n'est ce pas moi c'est moi j'ai
été happé par ce texte bon on en vient
au coeur du sujet john il a une fille
qui s'appelle alice qui vit avec sa mère
mais qui tous les week-ends va chez son
père chez john pour le voir la chambre
d'alice est celle qui fait face au lac
donc la fenêtre de la chambre d'alice et
face au lac elle aussi et c'est aussi ce
ration d'importance plus tard petite
précision je rappelle que dans les
fenêtres aux us et a souvent à une
moustiquaire vous savez un filet donc on
peut pas passer à travers puisqu'à la
moustiquaire qui bloque bond jeunes
explique que comme tous les papas du
monde il est fou amoureux de sa petite
fille compte les jours la semaine parce
qu'il a hâte d'être le week-end et de
l'avoir et il a la haine qu'il ya eu
l'ouragan rma parce que ça l'a empêché
de voir sa fille pendant trois semaines
bref il y en a et passer le courant
revient à la normale tout le monde a ri
de l'électricité à re confort dont elle
a besoin y compris john qui accueille de
nouveau sa petite fille chez lui tous
les week-ends et qui est au paradis
sauf que cette fois il se passe des
trucs très bizarre alice a commencé à se
plaindre auprès de john de la chanteuse
qu'elle n'aimait plus qu'elle ne voulait
plus voir
rien que ça alors bien évidemment john
et rationalise le truc donc il a d'abord
pensé qu'elle parlait soit son ex femme
soit d'un professeur à l'école soit
d'une copine dauphin d'un truc comme ça
sauf que dans la nuit du samedi
dimanche alice se réveille en lui
hurlant comme si elle avait eu l'honneur
il n'y a rien de pire pour un père que
ça je pense le coup de pression et total
john héroïque cours dans la chambre d'à
liste pour voir ce qui se passe il
allume la lumière et voit sa fille
cachée sous sa couette en train d'hurler
alors il lui demande ce qui s'est passé
et alice répondent delà de la pire
manière possible
elle montre un coin de la chambre du
doigt et elle dit regarde moi je ne
regarde pas le coin je prends alice je
saute par la fenêtre et je déménage
bodjona plus de courage que moi
apparemment ils regardent le coin et il
n'y a rien du tout ni dans le coin
nissou ligny dans le placard vraiment le
truc classique du film d'horreur il n'ya
rien mais alice insiste et lui dit il y
avait la chanteuse et je veux pas
qu'elle revienne je te plait pas prêts à
faire en sorte qu'elles reviennent pas
enfin les fantômes tu n'existes pas
rétabli ce john s'est dit que c'était
une mauvaise nuit ça arrive ya des nuits
on fait plein de cauchemar du coup il
autorise à dormir avec lui et pour le
moment ils réalisent pas à quel point
c'est grave ce qui se passe mais il a
quand même tel instinct parce que le
lendemain il va faire un truc très mal
il va aller acheter un babyphone vous
savez c'est comme des micros en gros il
ya un micro dans la chambre du gamin et
le parent entend tout ce qui se passe
dans la jambe ils achètent ça juste pour
rassurer la liste pour lui dire que
voilà il entendra tout ce qui se passe
et que s'il ya le moindre problème il
sera là en une seconde et qu'elle n'a
plus à s'en faire ou avoir peur ou est
stressé par cette histoire les baby
phone sont installés à lille s'endort
elle fait une nuit calme et paisible
tout se passe bien et john pense que
tout ça ça appartient maintenant au
passé et que ça n'arrivera plus qu à
l'erreur le week end après alice ne peut
pas venir chez john parce qu'elle est
tombée malade elle a chopé un petit
virus qui traînait à l'école et tant
mieux d'ailleurs je pensais pas dire ça
un jour mais tant mieux qu'elle soit
tombée malade
samedi soir deux heures du matin john se
réveille parce qu'il ya du bruit une
voix féminine qui fredonnent des
comptines dans le babyphone il est bien
réveillé il ne rêve pas et il entend
quelqu'un fredonner des comptines dans
la [ __ ] de chambre de sa fille il
explique qu'il a été pris d'une peur
totale et encore plus lorsqu'il a
entendu la personne dire la phrase
suivante
alice et tu réveiller john il saute de
son lit et verrouillé la porte de sa
chambre parce qu'il sait que sa fille
pour pas un danger puisqu'elle n'est pas
là elle est restée chez sa mère parce
qu'elle était malade
john prend son portable il l'appelle son
voisin steve qui kiffe les armes à feu
et qui est un ancien navy jouer et il
lui explique qu'il entend une meuf
chanter des berceuses dans la chambre de
sa fille steve hill part au quart de
tour il sort de chez lui à partir de là
jones sort enfin de sa chambre il court
devant pour rejoindre steve et y voit
steve en train de pointer avec une arme
une meuf qui est accroupie
terre et qui était la meuf qui s'amusait
à chanter des berceuses dans la chambre
de sa fille toutes les fois où alice a
dit à john qu'elle voulait plus que sept
personnes viennent chanter des berceuses
etc
c'était pas des cauchemars c'était bien
réel ya bien quelqu'un toutes ses nuits
qui s'est infiltrée chez john et qu'à
chanter des trucs à sa fille c'est
horrible tu dois dire [ __ ] ma fille
elle était en danger elle m'a prévenue
mais je n'ai pas cru tu va culpabiliser
comme jamais c'est horrible alors qu'il
était cette personne c'était jean la
femme du mec qui entretient le quartier
c'est une meuf qui fait des patrouilles
pour assurer la sécurité des gens du
quartier et du coup quand ils l'ont
grillé et qui lui ont dit qu'est ce que
tu foutais elle s'est défendue en disant
non mais je faisais une patrouille j'ai
cru voir quelqu'un entrer dans la
chambre de votre fille alors que bien
entendu ces patrouilles elle les fait
pas du tout à deux heures du matin elle
les faits le soir bien avant deux heures
du matin enfin bon voilà une rencontre
extrêmement grippi qui a dû se traduire
par un gros sentiment de culpabilité
pour john et sac est horrible dans cette
histoire c'est vraiment ton enfant tu
dis un truc qui tue rationalisme et
nantes inquiète tout va bien t'inquiète
sauf qu'il avait raison et du coup tout
ça a fini par l'installation de barreaux
à la fenêtre de la chambre de alice pour
que ça n'arrive plus jamais c'est triste
d'en arriver là mais je pense que quand
ça t'arrive tu mets des barreaux tu mets
de l'acier tu mets tout ce qu'il faut
pour être tranquille bref ça décale de
six ans et demi environ le moment où
j'aurai un enfant alors laisse moi
maintenant vous raconter l'histoire de
tom qui a une histoire qui va vous êtes
un petit peu plus familière parce que ça
s'est passé dans les bois et il a vécu
ce qu'aucun d'entre nous n'a envie de
vivre tu sais pas si vous êtes déjà
allés camper en forêt en colonie où je
dois par vous même ce que vous avez
envie de vous taper un petit kiff
forcément on a peur il ya plein de
petits bruits partout ça fait flipper et
parfois même on fait des rencontres
shelton décide d'aller quand perforé
avec trois de ses potes bennett kyle et
jones était peut-être même le john de
l'histoire d'avant si les a vraiment pas
eu de chance dans sa vie il explique que
c'est un délire qui font pour renouer
les liens chaque année vous en forêt ils
vont camper puisque depuis qu'ils sont
plus à université ben ils voient
beaucoup moins mais salomon
le premier jour tout s'est passé nickel
il arrive beau soleil met en place le
feu de camp les temps le soir il va un
petit peu de tout dans le colisée parce
que c'est meilleur pour la santé et ils
vont dormir en ayant passé une
merveilleuse journée bref tout va bien
y'a rien à dire le lendemain pareil
toute la journée tout se passe bien il
arrive en milieu de soirée et là ils
font un petit jeu pour s'amuser que je
trouve un peu atypique mais bon il se
plaquent au sol en boucle et ça les fait
marrer et dans la bataille en plein
délire de potes john se fige et dit aux
autres vous avez entendu entendu quoi
d'autre
tiens il fait un petit plaquage à john
pour lui remettre les idées en place ils
continuent à se plaquer ce bizarre ce
jeu je comprends toujours par dix
minutes plus tard ils sont crevés afin
d'avoir fait ce petit jeu ils se
décident d'aller se poser dans la tente
et la tomme en temps un petit
ricanements comme il était tous un peu
pompette homme se dit que c'est l'un de
ses potes qui ricanaient pour ce qui
s'était passé avant etc
il demande aux autres
entendu ce qui vient d'antan les autres
lui dise mais non c'est toi qui a rigolé
lui dit maintenant c'est pas moi qui ai
rigolé et après un petit blanc de 4
secondes
ils vont tous en courant dans la tendre
vers ça me fait rire c'est un réflexe
parce que rares sont les moments de ta
vie où tu es aussi vulnérable que dans
une tente en fait c'est vraiment
l'endroit où tu ne vois rien de ce qu'il
ya autour mais tout ce qui est autour
c'est ou tuer hachette et est cet homme
il prend la [ __ ] h qu'ils ont qui est
la seule arme qu'ils ont sur le
campement le seul truc avec lequel il
peut se défendre puisqu'il avait ça pour
couper du bois et faire du feu petite
précision tom et ses potes là ils sont
pas allés camper vous avez dans des
endroits qui sont dédiés à sa ou du coup
il ya plein d'autres campeurs il ya du
passage et c'est là ils sont juste aller
au bord d'une forêt en voiture ils ont
marché 1 km 5 vers le milieu de la forêt
ils ont foutu leur campement là ce qui
veut dire que si tu entends quelqu'un
rire et que c'est pas quelqu'un de ton
groupe ce n'est pas du tout normal
et en plus comme ce n'est pas prévu pour
les campeurs il n'y a pas de raison que
si un problème tu es baiser vous êtes
assez oppressé c'est bon moi c'est bouge
pas mal les dizaines de minutes passent
et tom vu qu'il était un peu pompette
hills assouplies et ils sont dehors il
est réveillé une heure plus tard par le
même [ __ ] de rire qu'ils ont entendu
avant après quelques secondes il voit un
doigt qui appuie sur la tente
à partir de là il sait qu'ils n'ont pas
halluciné et qu'il ya bien quelqu'un qui
est là la personne fait le tour de la
tente et arrive au niveau de l'entrée et
la ccoo plusieurs secondes sans qu'ils
ne se passerait la personne ne bouge
plus les gars dans la tente ne bouge
plus et tout le monde est probablement
en pls à espérer que tout se passe bien
et d'un coup
regardez vous regardez je suis désolé si
vous avez eu peur mais c'est ce qu'ils
ont vécu la personne secoue la tente en
criant bugatti google dit au quai cale
se réveille en hurlant et le mic à
l'entrée de la tente
rigole très fort de nouveau et se
cassent tom et ses amis ont passé le
reste de la nuit à ne pas dormir
à peine le soleil se lève tom et ses
potes cours à la voiture ils ont vu des
tas le et ils ont heureusement pas du
tout croisé quiconque sur le chemin donc
ils ne savent pas qui est venue cette
nuit là quelles étaient ses intentions
et surtout est ce qui leur serait arrivé
quelque chose s'il était sorti de la
tante quand le gars était là plein de
questions sans réponse par contre il ya
une question qui reste pas sans réponse
et ce qu'ils ont refait du contenant oui
sauf que maintenant ils vont dans les
fameux spot à camping où il ya des
espaces dédiés du coup pour le camping
est là on voit que c'est des américains
tom mann en amène toujours une arme à
feu toujours il a avec lui un gun qui a
pas plu rich un beau moral quand vous
aller camper fait pas n'importe quoi
n'allait pas au milieu d'une forêt vont
faire qu'il fait mais un blabla c'est
mieux d'aller dans des spots prévu pour
vous éviterez les grosses frayeurs comme
tom et ses amis cette nuit là ça l'a
vraiment traumatisé et je pense
effectivement pour avoir déjà fait du
camping tout si ça m'arrivait bon jeu
tu es toujours bon dernière histoire qui
est trop chaude ou c'est une mécanique
on n'a jamais vu avant c'est gratuit
c'est manger un truc gratuit dans la
gueule qui n'a aucun sens alors nova
c'est un mec qui a 17 ans et parents
sont partis en congés pendant un mois et
vit dans un petit quartier agréable
plutôt éloigné des autres quartiers qui
sont autour de celui-ci est ici plus
graves comme pour john comme ça un petit
quartier a souvent des petits événements
qui sont organisés pour réunir tous les
voisins noah et connaît donc presque
tous les habitants de son quartier il
peut presque donné le nom de tout le
monde elle et c'est un quartier qui est
très calme genre après 21h il ya plus de
bruit a plus personne dehors parce que
c'est que des familles et voilà ce très
posé noël son kif dans la vie c'est les
peinture en aérosol
un soir à 22h il décide qu'il a envie
d'en faire et du coup il va dans son
garage pourquoi parce que c'est la zone
la mieux ventiler de toute sa maison
bref 22h noah commence à tendre une
toile pour parle et là quelqu'un se
pointe devant son garage n'aura l'a
entendu arriver donc il s'apprête à
lever les yeux à dire bonjour à un
voisin sauf qu'il lève les yeux et voit
quelqu'un qui ne reconnaît pas il décrit
le gars comme étant un mec de 1 mètre 90
maigre et qui semble parfaitement normal
noah ne le connais pas mais il explique
que comme c'est un tout petit quartier
ils sont très sympas les uns avec les
autres y compris avec les gens qui
connaissent pas donc noah a pas de
raison de se méfier ça fait 17 ans qu'il
est sur la planète et 17 ont que bah
tout va bien il fait la dictée avec des
inconnus tout se passe bien donc il le
dit salut mec comment ça va tuer une
manière plutôt cordiale d'entamer la
conversation je vous la corde le gaz
présente donc à noah il dit qui
s'appelle xavier et qui vient
d'emménager dans la maison à l'angle de
leurs noah connaît la famille qui habite
dans la maison dont parle xavier et lui
dis donc à tabit chez les mineures et
xavier explique hanno à caen fait ses
ses cousins et qu'ils ont accepté de
l'héberger jusqu'à ce qu'ils règlent
quelques trucs honnêtement pour moment
y'a pas de quoi se méfier j'avais
ensuite dire je ferais mieux de partir
je dois faire quelque chose c'était
sympa de vous rencontrer n'aura pas
dormi noailles s'est jamais présenté
comment le gars le connaît mais xavier
lui dit que les miller lui ont beaucoup
parlé de lui ok alors nous ça peut un
peu nous choquer mais pas noah parce
qu'en fait il est assez proche des
milers il a même gardé des enfants à eux
quand ils étaient plus jeunes donc oui
c'est fortement possible qu'ils aient
parlé à leurs cousins de noix le
lendemain dimanche noah c'est un bg il
décide d'aller faire un petit footing
vers son lycée qui se situe environ à 5
km de chez lui et pas dans le qui
courent il ya une voiture qui se met à
rouler à sa hauteur et au volant bien
entendu c'est xavier xavier propose à
nos acquis et assez loin de chez lui 5
km de leur amener noah décline l'offre
explique qui kiffent courir qui va
rentrer en courant il adore ça et xavier
lui propose d'aller boire un café noël
très fermé et xavier absolument que
notre monde dans cette voiture c'est
inquiétant et là xavier ouvre la porte
passager fait un geste de la main à noah
pour lui indiquer de monter et il se met
il le dit viens monde dans la [ __ ] de
voitures tranquille pas tranquille du
tout j'ai refusé cinq fois bon la
noaille voit que xavier est un peu
insistants et du coup il décide de
prendre la fuite de lui dire c'est shao
j'ai des amis qui m'attendent à l'école
et il traça son école il y appelle un
ami pour qu'il vienne le chercher et il
voit au loin la voiture de xavier qui
est d'ailleurs toute cabossée ce bar et
quelques jours plus tard il ya un
barbecue chez des voisins tous les
voisins ils vont comme d'hab y compris
les miller noah va les voir par là vécu
et où d'un petit moment il leur dit au
fait j'ai rencontré xavier ce à quoi ils
répondent qu'ils aient xavier les miller
ne connaissent aucun xavier et encore
moins un certain xavier corps et
emménager chez eux qui seraient leurs
cousins donc le mec que noah déjà vu
deux fois est un pur mito dans le
quartier hier voisin qui est policier
qui s'appelle paul et du court ballet
miller et noir vont prévenir paul ii ce
que noah a vécu paul peut pas faire
grand-chose il juste à nora de l'appeler
si le croise il le voit au loin s'il ya
le moindre problème qui les aident pas
ils s'engagent aussi à faire des
patrouilles pendant plusieurs semaines
dans le quartier en espérant tomber sur
ce fameux xavier et découvrir quelles
sont ses intentions en fait puisque
c'est un gros mytho abacha de la pendant
deux semaines
plus aucune nouvelle de xavier de noah
ne le croise plus ne voit plus pense que
c'est du passé qui s'est définitivement
barrée avec sa voiture cabossée
sauf que non un soir noire entre assez
tard de chez un ami il va dans sa
cuisine commence à se faire à manger et
là il entend quelqu'un qui frappe à la
porte dans le doute il regarde dans
l'oeil de la porte et qui voient ce cher
xavier il sait que noah est là puisqu'il
a entendu venir vers la porte d'entrée
et du coup il lui dit qu'il s'excuse qui
voulait pas s'énerver qui passé une
mauvaise journée bref qu'il a merdé à ce
moment précis noir bas ce chiffre
totalement dessus il aimerait hurler et
direct aviez de dégager le menacé
d'appeler la police etc sauf qui a rien
qui sort vous savez ces moments
horribles où tu sais ce qu'il faut faire
et tu le fais pas parce que tu es
tétanisés par la peur c'est horrible
vous aviez enchaîne lui répète qui
s'excuse et lui demande d'ouvrir la
porte
il lui dit qu'il ne fera aucun mal il
veut juste que noël ouvre la porte
d'ailleurs il est celle ouvrir lui-même
sauf que la porte est verrouillée donc
il peut pas rentrer comme la dernière
fois en voiture il se met à s'énerver il
se met à crier sur noye pour qu'il ouvre
la porte et pendant ce temps-là noah ils
aidèrent la porte et il est tétanisé il
est là se faire crier dessus par un mec
qui connaît pas qui essaient d'entrer
chez lui par effraction c'est quoi cette
situation de merde
l'enfer vous avez continué à dominer la
porte à lui dire
r est à dire ils nous attendent il nous
attend est ce que ces mots font peur oui
à ce moment là le chien de noah
percutant freins qui intrigue anormale
qui se passe il descend de laitages et
il se met à aboyer sur la porte là on se
dit bon présence d'un chien ça fait
toujours flipper un mec qui veut rentrer
chez toi et qu'il doit les des trucs ou
qui venait de kidnapper tout simplement
pas du tout vous avez semé a rigolé et
il dit ils m'ont jamais dit que ça avait
un chien de qui parles mec grâce aux
aboiements de son chien doha et reprend
ses esprits il fonce dans le garage
parce qu'ils se souvient qu'il y avait
laissé son téléphone
il le prend et il appelle paul le fameux
flics du quartier il ya un petit temps
qui passe entre le moment où ils
appellent le moment où paul et la police
arrive et du coup quand ils sont arrivés
sur place xavier était plus là aucune
trace de xavier à partir de la pole il
part vivre quelques jours chez les
parents m'apprête à lui avec son pote
parce que bon c'est un peu traumatisant
ce qui est un dur quand même
et il revient quelques jours plus tard
une fois que ses parents à lui ont
changé toutes les serrures et porte de
la maison ils ont prise zéro risque et
ils ont eu raison
noah n'a plus jamais eu de nouvelles de
xavier la police a continué pendant un
mois à faire des patrouilles très
régulière dans le quartier ils sont
jamais tombés sur lui et du coup nos
ânes ne sait toujours pas ce que ce gars
lui voulait et c'est la question - ici
que j'ai c'était qui bordel qui fait ça
les amis c'est la femme ces trois
histoires d'horreur été assez longue
aujourd'hui mais en même temps plus le
temps passe plus les histoires qui
m'affecte sont celles qui sont assez
longues parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
détails beaucoup de contexte et c'est là
où je suis dedans je vous dis à bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo s'il ya des
moustiques laisser la fenêtre fermée
parce que la petite mouche kicker là bas
les gens passent à travers puis il
chante des chansons à vos enfants
à bientôt et comme toujours passer une
douce et agréable
bonne chance
[Musique]